key bonsoir à tous je suis ravi d'être
avec vous ce soir et j'ai le plaisir de
vous présenter une vue de paris en 2050
telle qu'imaginée par l'architecte
vincent callebaut
lors d'une étude réalisée pour la mairie
de paris autour de l'oxygénation et de
la densification des villes de demain
alors pourquoi est-ce que je vous
présente cette image ce soir c'est pas
parce que vincent callebaut et belge
c'est parce que cette image pour moi
elle représente une certaine vision
qu'on peut avoir des villes de demain
c'est-à-dire des villes au coeur
desquelles on va développer plus espaces
de nature plus espaces verts la deuxième
raison pour laquelle je vous présente
cette image ce soir c'est parce que
quand je la regarde cette image elle me
pose beaucoup de questions et en
particulier elle me pose de type de
questions premier type c'est de savoir
si demain on doit avoir des villes avec
+ espaces de nature
concrètement comment est ce qu'on fait
ça comment est-ce qu'on développe demain
comment est ce qu'on les conçoit
comment est-ce qu'on conçoit demain des
espaces de nature en ville est au coeur
des villes deuxième type de question
c'est de savoir qu'est ce qu'on en
attend quelles fonctions on attend de
ces espaces qu'on va développer en vie
alors j'ai pas la prétention ce soir de
répondre à toutes ces questions avec
vous mais j'aimerais simplement partager
des éléments de réflexion que j'ai pu et
qu'on a pu avoir à ce propos alors avant
d'aller plus loin
qui suis-je pour vous paraître ça ça
vous a été dit je m'appelle baptiste
grare je suis et colloques de formation
j'ai un master en ingénierie écologique
et j'ai ensuite réalisé une thèse sur
les potagers sur les toits et plus
particulièrement sur la recréation de
sol pour c'est dans le cadre de ces
potagers sur les toits
a la base je suis un petit urbain je
viens en banlieue parisienne et j'ai
toujours eu envie de transformer ce
milieu dans lequel je vivais en
particulier en y mettant justement plus
espaces verts pour le rendre plus
vivable
par ailleurs depuis le début de ma très
jeune carrière j'ai pu me rendre compte
que les villes sont au coeur des enjeux
environnementaux qui se posent à notre
société
pourquoi est ce que je dis ça je dis ça
parce que aujourd'hui plus de 50% de la
population mondiale vit au coeur des
villes
par ailleurs on sait que le milieu
urbain représente entre 60 et 80% des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
entre 60 et 80 % des consommations de
ressources énergétiques
donc on sait aujourd'hui que le milieu
urbain de part son développement et de
par son son développement et son
fonctionnement excusez-moi pose un
certain nombre d'enjeux environnementaux
on doit donc travailler aujourd'hui à sa
transformation et à son adaptation alors
au cas où il ya encore quelques
sceptiques dans la salle je vous propose
ici une image local de jambes en
l'occurrence pour vous convaincre du
caractère encore très minéral de nos
villes alors si on vient à la première
image que je vous ai présenté la
première question qu'on peut se poser en
particulier après ce que je vous ai dit
c'est au final pourquoi est-ce qu'on
devrait développer des espaces verts
dans les vides alors pour répondre à
cette question je vous promets je vous
propose un premier petit exercice
d'imagination vous allez venir avec moi
dans un parc et vous allez entrer dans
ce parc en entrant dans ce parc
vous allez voir des gens qui courent des
gens qui parlent des gens qui pique
nique en continuant à avancer dans ce
parc
vous allez je vous le souhaite en tout
cas voir un beau paysage
mais si vous regarder d'un peu plus près
vous allez voir aussi des pollinisateurs
de la biodiversité urbaine des espèces
qui viendront faire tout ou partie de
leur cycle de vie dans ce parc si vous
regardez encore un peu plus près vous
allez voir que le sol du parc
il est amendé par les jardiniers en
compost
on poste il est fait à partir de déchets
qui viennent de la ville il sert donc à
valoriser une partie de ces déchets si
vous regardez d'encore un peu plus près
vous allez voir que la végétation dans
ce parc
elle est comme vous enfin surtout comme
moi ce soir elle transpirait
l'évapotranspiration et en reléguant de
l'ol va refroidir localement la vie si
vous regardez là encore un peu plus près
vous allez voir que le sol et la
végétation
ils retiennent de l'eau il joue le rôle
d'épongé
pourquoi c'est important parce que
derrière cette eau qui va être retenu
elle ne va pas les surcharger les
réseaux d'assainissement de la ville
notamment en cas de grosse pluie
j'arrête là ma liste vous l'aurez
compris pourquoi est-ce qu'on doit
développer des espaces de nature en
ville parce qu'ils rendent des fonctions
et que ces fonctions sont importantes
pour nos villes de par l'impact
environnemental qu'elles ont alors
maintenant que j'espère vous êtes à peu
près tous convaincus de ça la question
qui se pose c'est concrètement est ce
qu'on va faire ça je pense que je vous
apprendrai en rien en vous disant que en
ville l'espace est rare et l'espace est
cher
quand on commence à s'intéresser à ces
questions de réserves foncières on
s'aperçoit que la première réserve
foncière
c'est ce qu'on va appeler les friches ou
les dents creuses qu'on va retrouver au
coeur des villes et dans leur périphérie
proche la deuxième réserve foncière à
laquelle on pense pas forcément
c'est les toitures les toitures c'est
aujourd'hui des espaces qui sont très
peu utilisées alors qu'ils peuvent
représenter jusqu'à 30% de la surface
horizontale d'une ville alors pour vous
convaincre de ça et puisqu'on m'a promis
que le public namurois et eris
d'imagination
je vais vous proposer un deuxième
exercice alors au cas où il n'est pas
que des namurois dans la salle j'ai
prévu quelques quelques images et des
petits objets pour ma compagne
vous allez imaginer que comme tous les
mercredis matins vous arrivez dans
l'immeuble dans lequel vous travaillez
vous asseyez à votre bureau et en vous
asseyant vous vous rappelez de la
conversation que vous avez eue la veille
avec un de vos collègues qui vous a
parlé de l'immense toiture que vous avez
au dessus de la tête
immense toiture plate
laquelle vous aviez jamais vraiment
pensé et le collègue vous conseille d'y
aller pour voir cette magnifique vue que
vous avez surtout namur alors vous
asseyant ce matin là vous promettez
camidi la première chose que vous ferez
c'est de monter sur ce toit est
justement à midi quand arrive la pause
directement vous montez sur la toiture
vous ouvrez la porte
première chose que vous voyez c'est
cette magnifique vue qui vous a été
promise
mais ce qui absorbe votre attention
c'est ce qu'il ya en dessous de vos
pieds qu'est ce que vous voyez est bien
vous voyez une membrane d'étanchéité qui
pourrait ressembler à ça ça sera mieux
et vous voyez également ceci c'est à
dire au delà de la membrane des
équipements de ventilation des
équipements techniques qui occupe
quasiment tout l'espace alors en voyant
ça vous vous dites pourquoi pas mais est
ce que c'est quand même pas un peu
dommage d'utiliser l'espace pour ça tout
en ayant cette réflexion vous continuez
à avancer sur la toiture en avançant
vous arrivez un deuxième espace danse
deuxième espace il ya toujours la
membrane
mais cette fois ci les équipements
techniques ont été repoussés sur le côté
et surtout sur cette membrane vous voyez
ce si ceux ci c'est du gravier du
gravier blanc
en voyant ça vous interroger pourquoi
est-ce que c'est là et là vous vous
rappelez une conversation vous avez il
ya deux semaines avec un copain qui
travaille dans le bâtiment et qui vous a
expliqué que si on mettait ce gravier
clair c'est parce que une des premières
raisons de première chose qui est ce
quinté membrane sur les toitures
c'est le rayonnement solaire direct et
les différences de température et petit
bonus ce gravier il retient un peu d'eau
donc en voyant ça vous dit c'est pas mal
mais est ce qu'on pourrait quand même
pas fermé sur 7
réflexion vous continuez à avancer sur
la toiture je préviens la toiture est
grand très grand
vous continuez à avancer et vous arrivez
dans une troisième zone qui pourrait
ressembler à ça ça c'est plus de 90% des
toitures végétalisées en france c'est à
dire cinq centimètres de sol avec par
dessus du seuil d'hommes qui sont des
plantes grasses et qui justement
végétalise cet espace en voyant ça vous
dit bon c'est quand même plus sympa que
ce qu'on avait avant
mais comme vous êtes curieux de nature
voulaient creuser et savoir ce qui
constitue ce sol entre eux quand vous
trouvez
ceux-ci se 6 et des billes d'argile et
bidart gils est utilisé notamment pour
les drains sur les toitures végétalisées
et ça vient comme leurs noms l'indiquent
de carrière d'argile d'où l'on exploite
large ils ont l'extrait on la malaxe on
va la chauffer a mis 100 degrés pour
obtenir ses billes et derrière on va
transporter ses billes jusqu'en ville
alors je pense que vous avez pas besoin
d'experts pour comprendre qu'il ya à la
fois un impact environnemental lié à
l'extraction d'exploitation et au
transport jusqu'à la ville pas forcément
situé à côté la carrière d'argile
bon vous dit ça mais bon en même temps
dit que c'est pas trop ma vous continuez
quand même votre recherche parce que
vous êtes vraiment curieux en continuant
votre recherche vous apercevez que dans
le substrat il ya un deuxième matériaux
ce matériau il vous faut d'abord penser
à de la pierre ponce c'est pas pour rien
parce que c'est de la roche volcanique
ça s'appelle de la pouzzolane sait
utiliser et c'est utilisé parce que
c'est très poreux laroche la pouzzolane
donc une roche volcanique comme son nom
l indique
ça vient de volcans qui sont exploités
dont on extrait la pouzzolane qu'on
amène ensuite envie pareil vous en
doutez les deux sont pas forcément à
côté
bon ou dit d'accord vous continuez votre
recherche pour tomber sur le troisième
constituant majoritaire de ces substrats
se constituant qu'est ce que c'est ces
luttes theron alors si je faisais un
sondage ce soir je pense qu'à peu près
tout le monde dans cette salle a déjà
utilisé ou au moins entendu parler du
terreau dons
pourquoi est-ce que le terreau ça pose
problème et bien parce que le terreau
s'est défini comme étant à base de
tourbe la tourbe ça vient des costumes
qui s'appelle des tourbières qui sont
des milieux humides et qui sont
indispensables notamment pour les
aspects de stockage de carbone de
préservation de la biodiversité et
d'épuration de l'eau est aujourd'hui
pour produire ce terreau on va drainer
ses milieux les assécher en sortir la
tourbe et ensuite l'amener en ville pour
végétaliser vu autrement on enlève des
fonctions d'un milieu naturel pour aller
essayer de les apporter en ville où
elles seront sans doute rang d'une
manière moins bonne et ben en arrivons à
ce constat vous arrivez et ces questions
donc que ça peut poser vous arrivez au
point de départ d'un projet de recherche
qu'on a lancé à agroparistech qu'une
école d'ingénieurs et à l'inra qui est
l'institut national de recherche
agronomique en 2012 et ce projet il
s'appelle le projet tkp pour toi
parisien productif projet pilote
c'est pas important de retenir le monde
je vous rassure dans ce projet
concrètement qu'est ce qu'on a fait eh
ben on a mis en place une
expérimentation sur une toiture qui est
située dans 5 ème arrondissement de
paris qui fait 800 m² est ce qu'on a
fait sur cette voiture c'est qu'on a mis
en place des bacs des bacs de culture
qui sont des compostières d'un peu moins
d'un mètre sur un mètre et à l'intérieur
de ces bacs
mon ami différents mélanges de matériaux
alors c'est pas du sol qu'on a sur ce
toit on appelle ça un techno sol ou un
entrepôt seul construit pourquoi parce
que ce qu'il ya dans nos bacs
c'est uniquement des matériaux qu'on va
apporter de la ville uniquement des
résidus qui viennent de la ville et
c'est vraiment là l'objectif du projet
c'est de voir est ce qu'on peut arriver
à cultiver sur les toits uniquement à
partir de résidus et de déchets qui en
viennent alors pour vous illustrer un
petit peu mon propos je vous ai ramené
aussi quelques matériaux le premier que
vous connaissez sans doute vous utilisez
en tout cas couramment c'est du marc de
café
sauf que ce marc de café il est un peu
particulier parce qu'il a servie avant à
faire pousser des champignons dans les
caves et nous on récupère ce marc de
café
après quelques champignons et pousser
deuxième matériaux qu'on utilise c'est
du bois broyé ce bois broyé il vient
concrètement de l'élagage des arbres
d'une ville qui ensuite broyés
grossièrement et non l'utilisent comme
une composante des technos hall qu'on a
sur notre toit troisième matériaux qu'on
a pu utiliser auquel on pense pas
forcément
c'est de la brique et de la tuile
concassées c'est un déchet du bâtiment
ou un des chefs fabrication de ces deux
matériaux
il faut savoir que les déchets du
bâtiment en volume c'est le premier
gisement en ville sauf que les filières
existent pas forcément pour le moment
dernier matériau qu'on a pu utiliser que
vous connaissez je pense tous ces du
compost en l'occurrence on a utilisé
deux types de compost à compost
bon j'arrête de faire ça c'est bon ça va
être terrible un premier type de compost
qui a compose de déchets verts qui vient
de l'entretien des espaces verts et à
compose de biodéchets qui est fait à
partir des épluchures de cuisine qu'on
produit vous et moi au quotidien
donc voila un petit peu pour vous
illustrer ce qu'on a ce qu'on a pu
utiliser dans le cadre de ces
expérimentations
alors j'aimerais vous présenter
l'intégralité de nos résultats vous en
parler toute la soirée
le temps étant réduits je vous invite si
ça vous intéresse allez voir sur le site
d'agroparistech où les principaux
résultats sont présentés ou à lire un
magnifique ouvrage en l'occurrence ma
tête
mais malgré tout j'ai quand même envie
de partager avec vous ce soir trois
grands résultats qu'on a pu avoir
premier grand résultat c'est par rapport
à la production alimentaire la question
qu'on s'est posée c'est de savoir est ce
qu en utilisant uniquement des résidus
qui viennent de la ville on allait
pouvoir avoir des rendements qui sont
importants alors le résultat qu'on a eu
c'est de voir que sur six années on a
cultivé dans nos bacs on arriver à des
rendements qui étaient équivalents à
ceux de maraîchers biologiques en plein
saut ça résultat qui est intéressant qui
montre qu'on peut arriver à des
rendements importants même en utilisant
uniquement des déchets qui viennent de
la ville
pour autant on va pas nourrir demain
paris ou d'autres villes avec cette fois
on sait que l'agriculture urbaine
nourrira pas les villes de demain mais
ça montre qu'on peut arriver à des
rendements intéressants
deuxième question qu'on s'est posée et
qui est d'ailleurs souvent la première
que les gens nous pose c'est de savoir
si ce qu'on produisait allait pas être
pollué
pour répondre à cette question on s'est
intéressé à des contaminants qui sont
des éléments traces métalliques le plomb
le cadmium le zinc est ce qu'on a pu
montrer dans le résultat c'est que pour
l'immense majorité de nos cultures on
avait des toners largement inférieur aux
normes pareil c'est un résultat qui
était intéressante que ça montre qu'on
peut produire des légumes sains
lorsqu'on est sur un toit avec un sol
qui à la base sains et tout en n'étant
pas forcément proche de très grosses
sources de pollution dans notre cas
qu'est ce que ça veut dire pour les
projets d'agriculture ben ça veut dire
que c'est faisable mais qu'il faut
prendre en compte notamment
l'environnement dans lequel va se mettre
ce projet et le sol en place lorsqu'on
cultive dans un seul 3e résultats qu'on
a eus qui est sans doute le plus
important c'est de montrer que cette
voiture
elles sont multifonctionnel on a souvent
tendance à regarder cette fonction de
production alimentaire
alors qu'en fait la vraie raison sans
doute de développer ses projets demain
ça va être pour le fait qu'ils
retiennent de l'eau qui sont un
réservoir de biodiversité qui valorise
les déchets etc etc c'est pour ses
autres fonctions qu on sera sans doute
amené à développer ses projets alors
avant de conclure comme vous le voyez
notre projet ils montrent une
opportunité à développer ce type de
potagers sur les toits alors j'ai déjà
une bonne nouvelle c'est qu'on n'est pas
les seuls à le faire avant nous en même
temps que nous et après nous je l'espère
beaucoup d'initiatives d'agriculture
urbaine se développe un peu partout mais
j'aimerais conclure en me posant une
question et en vous posant une question
qui me taraude à savoir est ce que
réellement on va réussir à développer
ses projets à large échelle
alors honnêtement j'en sais rien je suis
pas devin et je compte pas forcément
développer des talents de ce côté là
mais j'aimerais partager avec vous trois
souhaits le premier souhait ça serait
que les pouvoirs publics à toute échelle
la ville le département la région l'état
favorise les conditions d'implantation
de projets d'agriculture urbaine et plus
généralement de nature en ville en ayant
un regard voire une exigence sur la
qualité de ses projets c'est à dire à la
fois à leur conception est à la fois les
fonctions qu'on en attend il ya des
collectivités qui commencent à
s'intéresser à ces questions mais pas
forcément de manière large pour le
moment deuxième souhait qui pareille
commence à être réalisés ces dix
associations et des entreprises
s'emparent du sujet pour développer des
modèles qu'ils soient multiples qui
répond justement à des contextes et des
enjeux qui sont différents en fonction
des villes pour développer demain des
projets d'agriculture urbaine qui
répondent à la fois aux besoins des
urbains et du milieu urbain mon
troisième souhait alors au début je
voulais vous dire que vous pouviez
chacun vous engager de manière directe
indirecte pour favoriser le
développement de projets d'agriculture
urbaine mais ça vous savez déjà
alors au vu du titre du ted je voudrais
vous proposer une résolution cette
résolution ça serait premièrement de
composter
si vous êtes en maison de lombricompost
et si vous êtes dans un appartement les
presque les plus parlants 200 kg de
déchets compostables que vous produisez
chaque année une fois que vous aurez
composter au lombricompostage vos
résidus d'utiliser ce compost selon
bricon postes dans des bacs dans une
jardinière au pied d'un arbre d'y
planter une graine de la rose et je vous
conseille
et pourquoi pas d'obtenir au bout de
quelques mois une belle salade comme ça
qu'ils commencent les traits un peu mais
qui reste belle ou des tomates ou des
courges
pourquoi faire ça eh ben pour
concrètement réaliser l'idée que nous
pouvons avoir des villes qu'ils soient
plus durable plus vivable plus
circulaire et pourquoi pas plus
cultivables merci à tous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
coc